Good afternoon everyone, my name is Athef Hassan and I am a PhD student at the Department
of AI at IIT Kharagpur and I will be taking you through the hands-on session today.
So before we begin with the hands-on session, I would like to talk about some good coding
practices. So the most important thing here is object-oriented programming. So the thing
is that we want to build modular code. Now why is that important? Because modular code
allows you to do a lot of things with ease in a plug-and-play manner and this is how
most of the code is implemented on other libraries as well such as Hugging Face and other PyPy
Torch, TorchVision and so on. So what we will see first is how to write good code so that
later on you don't face any issues in writing code or using other libraries. So the first
and foremost thing that when you write a deep learning code is that you need a model, right?
You need a model that will train on and what will you train on? You will train on data.
So you need the data as well. So these are the two most important aspects and the best
part about modular code is that you can actually take, let's say for example, the data module
and then you can pass in certain parameters that allow you to change the type of data,
the different normalization methods that you use to normalize your data and so on. Similarly
for the model, you can actually change the stride when you are using convolution, you
can change the stride, you can change the number of parameters and so on with a lot
of ease and allows you to do a lot of things. For example, in ensemble learning where you
have to have multiple models, so instead of writing multiple functions, you can just have
a single class and then call that class multiple times that is creating objects of that class.
And then finally we need a driver function which is the main file or the main function
where we basically create the model object, we create the data object and then we train
the model. So these are the three things that are mostly required for training any deep
learning model. So the first thing as you can see in the my model class, there are few
things here that I would like to go over quickly before we start working on the deep learning
hands on session. So what we have here is the my model class and the my model class consists
of a constructor. So if you are people who are aware, who have worked with Java are aware
of something called the constructor. So the idea here is that in the constructor you define
all the variables or all the parameters that you want to use in the model. So all of the
parameters supposed to be registered or created in the init function which is the constructor
in Python. Once you have defined your constructor, you need to define your forward function.
So what is this forward function? So we will be using PyTorch library, we are not using
TensorFlow. So in the PyTorch library, the forward function is basically a way of defining
how your data would forward propagate through the model. Because PyTorch essentially, if
you boil everything down PyTorch is essentially a back propagation method, a back propagation
library or an auto differentiation library. So it allows you to differentiate things.
So for differentiation to take place, you need to define the equations. So once you
define the equations, differentiation automatically happen for you. So the forward function here
takes all of those equations. The way you want, for example, in residual connections,
you want to add some input to the output of the next to next layer. So that is one way
of defining your equations. In VGG, for example, it is a completely sequential. So one input
goes to the output of one layer goes to the input of another layer and so on. So there
are many ways of defining how you want to perform the forward pass or how you want the
data to forward propagate through the model. And all of that logic needs to go into the
forward function. And this forward function, the PyTorch will use to auto differentiate
and get you all the gradients. There are three other functions that I usually define. And
it is good practice. In fact, there's a very famous library called PyTorch Lightning, which
is built on PyTorch. And it's a very nice library in the sense that it allows you to
modularize your code and it reduces a lot of mess. And its signature of working is defining
these three extra functions, which is called configure optimizers training step and validation
step.
In the configure optimizers, we define what sort of optimizer we want to use. For example,
stochastic gradient descent, add them add them w and so on. I believe all of these things
have already been taught or have been covered in previous classes. Then we have training
step, which defines how, what you're going to do in a single iteration. And then finally
we have the validation step, which is again, what you want to do in each iteration on the
validation data itself. So these are the few functions that are part of the class model.
Then we come to the data module class. So the data module class as well again has the
init function, but we also define a few other functions like prepare data, set up train
data loader and valid data loader. So in the prepare data, we do all the pre-processing,
like downloading the data and loading it in whatsoever manner we wish. Then we have the
set up where we create the data set. So all the pre-processing, such as normalization
of the data will go into prepare data and then the set up part, which is basically creating
the data set. And we'll see what creating the data set means a little later. So you
create the data set and once you've created the data set, the train data loader and valid
data loader is simply helper function that you use to return the data loaders that you
create. Finally, we have the main function where we call the my model class, where you
call the data model class and then we write the training logic. That's it. So this is
a broad overview of how you're supposed to write code. I mean, this is the best method
that I believe will help you write code efficiently. But there are other ways as well. You can
always try that out. This is my personal preference.
So now we will be looking at two things or two experiments rather. We'll be going through
two notebooks. So Plavansar talked about a lot of pre-trained models and we'll pick some
of those ideas and we'll try to convert them into practical code. Now, the first thing
that we would like to see is what sort of pre-trained data is best for your current
data set. So obviously, as you can understand, there are millions and n number of data sets
out there. And you will find a lot of pre-trained models as well. But is one sort of pre-training
data set good for your particular data set or not? Or in other words, we can say that
is the knowledge from one data set transferable to another data set? This we would like to
see and understand. So for this purpose, what we'll do is we'll pick up ImageNet, that
will be a pre-trained model. So our model is pre-trained on the ImageNet 1K data set,
very general data set. And what we'll do is we'll train, we'll use the model pre-trained
on ImageNet and we'll try to look at how the knowledge from ImageNet adapts to CIFAR
10 and fashion MNIST. These are two separate data sets. So this is one sort of set of experiments.
We will try to see whether a pre-trained, the data set that the pre-training data set
that we have, the knowledge that we gain from that pre-training data set, whether that is
transferable to all data sets. That is one thing that we'll see. And then the next problem
that we'll face is the shallow versus deep fine tuning versus training from scratch,
which is again something that Lawans have talked about. So what we'll try to see is that which
one works better? When you have a full pre-trained model for your, and you want to use this model
for your data set, which one works better? Should we simply tune only, should we tune
the entire data set, entire model? Should we tune only a part of the model? Should we tune
only just the head of the model? And you'll see what the head actually means here. Or
should we train the entire model from scratch without using the knowledge of the pre-trained
data set? So we'll go over all of these, we'll go over all of these experiments and
hopefully this will clear things out for you. So just a quick look at what the ImageNet
and the CIFAR-10 or CIFAR-100 data set will look like. So you can see the ImageNet data
set is a very general data set and it contains a lot of images from varied sources. As you
can understand, we're using only a subset of ImageNet, which is called ImageNet-1K,
which is, this is one of the more popular data sets, or popular subsets of the entire
ImageNet data set. So that is the idea. And then CIFAR-10 or CIFAR-100 is another data
set. It's much more lower resolution. So I believe this is 32 by 32, while ImageNet-1K
goes up to 512 by 512, or even bigger sometimes. But CIFAR-10, CIFAR-100, these are very, these
are nicely behaved data sets in the sense that you get, all of the images are of the
same size. And there are, in CIFAR-10, there are 10 classes and in CIFAR-100, those classes
are basically much more fine grained. So for example, if you have a DAW class, you'll
have much more fine grained classes. For example, within the DAW class, whether you
have Poodle or Labrador and all of those classes. So CIFAR-100 is a more fine grained version
of CIFAR-10. So these are the data sets that we'll be looking at. So now we'll move on
to the notebooks. So I hope my screen is visible. So we'll start off, we'll start off with a
domain adaptation problem, which is whether using a particular pre-trained data set or
a model from a particular pre-trained data set, whether that is applicable to your data
or not. This is a very important question and this can make or break the performance
of the model on your data set. So we'll see which one, what sort of pre-trained data set
is good for your particular data set. So first of all, what you are going to do is, you are
going to import all the necessary libraries and we'll be using these libraries. So the
rest assured, I'll be explaining everything. So first of all, what we are going to do is,
we are going to set up the data set class that we just talked about. So in our case,
we are using the CIFAR-10 and the fashion MNIST data set. So the fashion MNIST data set is
kind of like the MNIST data set, which is a data set of hand digits recognition. So it
basically consists of handwritten digits. The fashion MNIST is a drop in replacement
for MNIST in the sense that instead of having handwritten digits, it now has boots, shirts,
trousers and all of these images. And again, it has 10, just like the MNIST data set, it
has 10 classes. So it has bags, handbags basically, boots or shoes, trousers, these are all separate
classes. So first we are going to set up the data set. So we are creating the class, the
data module class. Again, if whenever you create a class, you need a constructor. So in the
constructor, we have a particular keyword or variable called fMNIST. So if you set this
to true, what is going to happen is that it's going to, so if self.fMNIST is true, we are
going to have certain different types of transformations on the data set. And if fMNIST is false, then
we are going to have certain different transformations on the data set.
So the first thing is we have to call the super function, which is basically the inherited,
so we are obviously inheriting. So PyTorch expects you to make sure that you inherit
or call the constructor of the super class or the class from which you are inheriting.
Next up is we are defining the batch size, then we have this function, variable called
self.mNIST. So the self keyword here basically allows us to refer to the current object.
So you can have multiple objects, right? So the Python needs a way to understand which
object you are referring to. So self allows you to do that. So we have self.fMNIST equals
to fMNIST. So we are assigning whatever fMNIST value we want. The default is set to false,
but you can obviously assign whatever value you want.
Next up we are going to define some augmentations on the data. So what do we mean by augmentations?
As you can understand, you have set of images. Now if you train these images as is and you
do not provide any changes in the images itself, the model has a very limited scope of understanding.
So for example, I give you a very short analogy. So the idea was that for, I do not know, this
is probably a fiction, but we will go over the story. So the story goes like this that
during World War, one of the scientists said that he can actually build an AI that can
help the Americans or the Europeans or the Allied forces basically to recognize where
those Panzer tanks, the tanks from Germany are in forests. So those German tanks were
very good at camouflaging. So people went and they clicked a lot of photos and then they
sent those photos to the scientists and the scientists build an artificial intelligence
model, a kind of pseudo neural network and it was actually performing really well. It
was able to identify from those forests, from the trees it was able to identify where a
particular tank is available or where the tank is standing. But the problem was that
the images that were taken were taken in broad daylight. So now what happened was that whenever
there were tanks under shadow or during nighttime, the model did not work at all because the
images that it were fed were just for images in daylight. So that was a very big problem
and that is where this idea of augmentation stems. So the idea is that you do not want
to give images of only one kind to the model, you want to diversify the images as much as
possible. Now if you want to diversify images, you need to click pictures of the same subject
under shadow or during nighttime or during daytime, during noon time when you have no
shadows for example when it is cloudy and all of these situations that is very difficult
to do. So instead can we take one picture, let us say we take a picture of a person in
daylight and can we actually apply augmentation such that we can replicate all of these scenarios
without having to click more photos. So that is what augmentation, the idea of augmentation
is. So what are these types of augmentations we are applying? Well we are applying some
basic augmentations. So we are taking resize, so the idea is we are taking this 32 by 32
image of let us say C for 10 or 28 by 28 image of fMNIST and we are going to resize it 256
by 256. So we are making the image bigger and why are we doing that is because the model
is trained on ImageNet, compress the images that are like 512 or maybe even 1024 in size.
They push it down or compress it down to 256. So the default training is 256 by 256 for
the models that we are going to use. Obviously there are other ways of going about it. There
are other models that use 224 by 224 or they use 384 by 384 and so on. But the idea is
that you want to resize your images to whatever version your pre-trained model was trained
with. So in this case because a pre-trained model, whatever model we are going to use
later on, that model was pre-trained using 256 by 256 size. So we are going to use that.
Then we have random crop. So we are going to randomly crop the image. So it can be cropped
from any side. So that will induce some sort of camera clicking angle. So there are sometimes
you can click a person from far. Sometimes you can click a person from near. So we want
to use that information as well. We want to simulate that as well. So random crop helps
us in doing so. Then we have random horizontal flip. So sometimes we are going to flip the
image to the left or to the right and so on. And then we have two tensors which is basically
going to take those images which will be loading as PIL images. We will be converting them
to tensors and then finally we are going to normalize those images. Now why are we normalizing
and what does these numbers mean? So we are expecting three channel images or RGB images.
So these three values denote the three channel. So what we are going to do is we are going
to normalize or we are going to subtract these values which is basically the mean of channel
1, mean of channel 2 and finally mean of channel 3. So we are going to subtract these means
from all these three channels and these are the variances of the standard deviation. So
we are going to take the standard deviation and we are going to divide each channel with
these. So we are basically standardizing each channel in our dataset. Why are we doing this?
It is because the values of the images are pretty large. Usually it is between 0 to 255
for each channel where 0 means complete blackness and 255 means white. So when you have RGB,
255 in R would mean complete red, in G it would mean complete green and in D it would
mean complete blue. So these are very large values and training our model initialization
usually starts from between -1 to 1. So you would have to train whenever you are training
a model, the model parameter values need to increase to a large number so that you can
accommodate training these values. So instead what we can do is we can actually normalize,
standardize and make sure our images are also between -1 to 1. So it does not take a lot
of time for training the model to convergence rather it quickly converges. So that is the
whole idea of normalization. So this is for training as you can understand but for validation
as you can understand we probably do not need to randomly crop the image neither do we need
to randomly flip the image. It is because you want to test the model on the images that
you are providing which is the test set of the validation set. So the only thing that
you want to do is you want to resize the images so that there is no difference in the distribution
of the images in terms of size between the validation and the training data set.
Then again we have to convert these images to tensors and then we have to normalize.
So these three lines make sure that our validation of the test data set is not distributionally
different from the training data set. Now if the data is FMNIST you want to add some
extra transformation which is the grayscale transformation. So now the FMNIST as I said
is a drop in replacement of MNIST and MNIST is a grayscale data set that is it contains
only one channel. So we have only blacks and whites or grays but we want to make sure that
we have three channels because of model as we have already said we will be using model
pre-trained on the image net data set which is an RGB data set. So we need three channels.
So the grayscale and in brackets 3 what this means is that it is going to take the image
and it is going to convert it into grayscale and it is going to copy that one channel which
because we have one channel into three channels. So now you have three channels albeit all
of them are exactly the same. So in effect we have three channels and then we are going
to apply whatever transformations that we have explained here.
So that was our init function now we have we have all the transformations that are
required we will go we will now go into the prepare data and we will set up our data set.
So in the prepare data function what we are doing is we have the self-rot train set again
here we are defining three separate two separate variables the train set and the validation
set. So now what does the train set contains it contains the data set. So what is this
data set this data set is basically an iterable so when you have a large amount of data PyTorch
provides you a way of converting that data into an iterable.
So what you will be doing is what PyTorch will be doing is when you are given an iterable
it take batches of data extract batches of data and provide it to you. So the fashion
eminence this is basically a data set it is derived from the PyTorch data set class this
is already been built for us and where does this come from. So if you look at the import
you will find that we have the fashion eminence and cfr10 from torchvision.datasets. Torchvision
is again a very nice library that is available to us by PyTorch and you can use it has a
lot of functionality for vision related tasks. So it already provides us with the fashion
eminence data set as well as the cfr10 data set. So we do not have to define our own iterable
but rather we can use the iterable provided by torchvision itself.
So we are going to use fashion eminence we are going to pass whatever the data we have
downloaded exists the train set and the validation set so true and false and if it is not available
we do not have the data you can also download it and it will get saved in this directory
and whatever transformation we require can be applied using the transformation that we
have just talked about. Finally once we have we have prepared the data set we will go into
the setup function where we create the data loader. So once we have an iterable the data
loader it uses that iterable to pick batches of data. Once it picks batches of data you
can use that batch of data to do whatever you want with the model. So this comes from
the data loader class which requires a data set and whatever batch size you want and whether
you want shuffle to be true or not so we are going to shuffle the data set to make sure
that the model does not learn in a particular sequence rather we are providing different
sequences to the model.
And finally we have these two functions as I talked about these are simply helper functions
that will return the data loader that you have trained and that you have created. So
once our data class is generated created we will go to the model class. Now in the model
class what we have is we are taking a few hyper parameters so the first thing is number
of classes this will be used later on I will show where then we have pre-trained equals
to 2 so whether we want to use the pre-trained model or not by default it is set to 2 because
in this example we want to use the pre-trained model and see where this model is more applicable
to which data set and then we have number of unfreeze layers again we will go over what
this means in the next set of experiments not this experiment here.
So if pre-trained is true what we will do is we will use the ResNet 18 model again provided
by TorchVision so if you go up here we will see that the ResNet 18 model is provided by
TorchVision and it is models class. So we are going to load the ResNet 18 model and
the weights are going to be the ResNet 18 weights default which basically is a keyword
for saying we are going to use the latest ImageNet weights for ResNet 18. So we now
have a pre-trained model that is ready but what we want to do is we want to make sure
that we are not training the entire model we are only training the head.
So again what the head means I will explain that just in a bit but first thing is that
we want to make sure that the entire model is frozen as Sir had talked about. So the
way of doing that is you want to take the variable where you have stored the model and
you want to set its required grad to false. So what happens is that each parameter is
going to be frozen. Now what this means will go over in the next set of experiments and
if you are not using pre-trained then again we will have the ResNet 18 model but our weights
is going to be none so we are loading the model from scratch and we are going to have
all of the parameters we are going to make sure that PyTorch generates gradients for
all of the parameters. Finally what you will see here is that we are replacing the top
most layer so as you can understand in ImageNet 1k the 1k stands for 1000 classes alright.
So there are 1000 classes in the ImageNet 1k subset of the ImageNet dataset and the
model was trained to identify 1000 classes but in our case we are using fMNIST and CIFR10
and both of them have only 10 classes. So there is a mismatch right so our model is
going to produce 1000 classes as output but you want only 10 classes. So what can we do?
We can replace the top most layer which we call the head. So we are going to replace the
head with a new linear layer which is going to take input as 512 and going to output the
number of classes. So why 512? It is because that is the last output from the last convolution
layer in the ResNet 18 model sorry. So the model outputs a 512 vector for a single image
and we are going to take that 512 vector and apply a matrix or a linear layer which takes
that 512 and converts it into the number of classes alright. So if you are going to freeze
the entire model and replace the only the head so that is the only part which we need
to train the entire rest of the model which is the convolution which has saved the generalized
features from the pre-trained data set that is not going to change.
Finally we have we are defining a few more things. We have the criterion which is basically
the loss function of the objective function that you want to use and certain metrics which
is strain accuracy and validation accuracy. So this comes from the torch metrics class
again you will see that it is available here. So torch metrics is another nice library that
allows us to use different metrics for example F1 score, accuracy, recall, precision and so
on. You do not have to write all of that code yourself you can use it from torch metrics
library so that is what I have done here. So in the accuracy class when you create the
object of the accuracy class you need to pass what type of task you are using. So in this
case you are using a multi-class task and then what are the number of classes.
The function that we have talked about previously in the slide which is configure optimizers
here we are going to use the SGD optimizer with given number of parameters so which is
basically whatever the model parameter that you have defined in the init function. Then
we have the learning rate and momentum that you want to set. And finally we have the scheduler
so the idea of a scheduler is that you do not want to use the exact same learning rate
throughout the training period rather you want to change that learning rate because when
you are training the models right at the beginning trains very quickly and then later on the
performance improvements start saturating. So in that period of initially you want to
use a large learning rate so you can maximize the performance gain and then as the learning
rate starts to saturate, as the training performance starts to saturate you want to use smaller
and smaller learning rate because you are getting closer and closer to the final local
minima. So that is the idea of the scheduler.
Then we have the forward function. In the forward function as we have talked about we
are just going to take all of that data and we pass it through the backbone. Now this
backbone variable the ResNet18 that particular object already has a forward function defined
within it. So we can just call the surf.backbone and when we pass this data x, the variable
x contains the data. When we pass this through the model it will automatically call the models
forward function and the data will pass through there. And whatever output we get is going
to be returned. Then we have the iteration. What happens when single iteration? So we
will first zero out the gradients from the computation graph. So PyTorch creates a computation
graph whenever you create a model and the idea is that you want to make sure that this
computation graph is empty. So there are no gradients in the graph. So you are zeroing
out otherwise the problem will be that there might be some gradients remaining, some values
on those on the edges of those computation graph which might cause calculation or computation
issues for the next iteration when you are calculating gradients for the next iteration.
Then we have the forward function which creates the forward pass. Once you get the predictions
from the model which is going to be the number of classes that we have just defined. What
we will be doing is we are going to use these predictions to update the training accuracy.
Finally we are going to pass that whatever predictions we have we are going to pass it
to the objective function that we have defined. So we have the target, we have the predictions,
we will pass it to the cross entropy loss and get the loss value. Then we are going
to perform back propagation. So we will calculate the loss for each of the parameters using
the chain rule and then the optimizer dot step what this will do is it will update the
values and update the parameters using the loss values that you have calculated using
the chain rule. Finally we are returning the loss dot item. So this is a helper function
that will basically allow us to print out the loss and see what happens.
Now there are some other functions, extra functions that I have defined so on training
epoch and so what happens once the training completes or one epoch of the training completes.
So what is one epoch? It is basically a complete pass over your entire data once. So when you
are iterating you are iterating over single batches. So once all of the batches are complete
that is what we call an epoch. So what happens at the end of the training over one epoch
when we are going to print out the accuracy that you have just calculated.
Similarly for the validation step here you do not need the loss all you need to do is
update the accuracies. So that is what we have done. By not requiring the loss I mean
you do not need to update the parameters or calculate or perform chain rule calculation
and so on. There is no back propagation required. So I will just calculate the loss and return
it. And again what happens at the end of the validation over a single epoch so we just
print out the accuracies. And then the reset matrix is used to reset the matrix that we
have used for a single epoch. So once after a single epoch you still have those values
with the accuracy values you want to reset them so that you can calculate a fresh for
the new epochs. So we now have the data class and we have the model class. Now we put everything
together. So for CIFAR 10 we are using these particular hyper parameters. So we generate
the data module, we prepare the data, we set it up and we load our data loaders. These
variables we are going to use these variables to store the accuracies so that we can plot
it out later on. Then we will define the model which again will use all of these hyper parameters
and we will define in the configure optimizers function we will pass all of these hyper parameters
as well. Finally what we are going to do is we are going to train the model. So as I said
previously in the slides in the main function we will be calling, we will be defining the
logic on how to train your model over the entire training period.
So the first thing is in each epoch whatever number of epochs you have defined your model
to train we have defined I believe here it is 10, yes it is 10 here. So we will set a
model into training phase. So what does it, what does this mean model.train it is going
to take your model and set it to training phase. So what is the difference between train and
then model.eval model.train. So there are a lot of other layers such as batch norm or
dropout. For example in dropout you randomly drop certain neurons in your model. Now when
you set it to model.train dropout will work as is but when you want to validate you do
not want to apply dropout. So in order to do that you have to set the flag model.eval.
So what PyTorch does is that in this model.eval function it sets the eval flag to 2 when the
eval flag is set to 2 meaning evaluation the model needs to be evaluated dropout is set
to false automatically. So you do not have to do you know you do not have to write code
separately for your batch normalization or your dropout rather you can just do model.eval
and the PyTorch will take care of it by itself.
So for each epoch we pick up the batch. So for each iteration we pick up a batch of data
and then we pass it to the training step and we get our loss and we create an average of
the losses and we also have the training accuracy which we are saving and we will save the c
fat whatever training loss we are getting we are saving that into the particular variable.
So we do the same thing for the validation as well and finally we are going to reset
the matrix so that in the next epoch again we can use the same matrix. So I have already
trained this it takes some time to train so I have already trained this before and as
you can see our training accuracy starts from 77% top 1 and 96% top 5 and our validation
accuracy starts from 89% because we are using the pre-trained model so model already has
a lot of that information stored in itself. So finally we will see that we get a validation
accuracy of 95% and top 5 is basically nearly 100% accuracy.
So this is for CIFAR 10 and the idea is that we expect this performance improvement because
the CIFAR 10 as I have shown in the slide is reminiscent of the ImageNet dataset itself
because the ImageNet is a very dataset and a lot of information on natural images. Similarly
CIFAR 10 although it is small and lower resolution but it also comes from natural images. So we
expect that whatever models pre-trained on the ImageNet dataset will actually whatever
knowledge the pre-trained model has taken from the ImageNet 1K dataset that will be
transferable to CIFAR 10 because both of them contain subsets of naturally occurring images.
But what do we expect for fashion MNIST? Fashion MNIST as I have said is a grayscale image
first of all so it does not have RGB channel it has only one single channel. Second of all these
are not natural images rather these are images of boots and trousers they have nothing to do with
images occurring naturally. So what we expect is that the data the knowledge is not very transferable
from the ImageNet 1K dataset to fashion MNIST. So ideally what we should be seeing is that the
performance improvements that we have seen on CIFAR 10 that is achieving such high accuracies
should not be possible for fashion MNIST. That is the logic behind this experiment.
So again we have already defined everything that we need so we will just define the hyper
parameters write out create the data model write out the training loop again and then train the model.
So once training is complete we will compare the loss and we will compare the validation
accuracy how are we doing that we are using the C-Born library for this the matplotlib and C-Born
library. So we pass the loss values that we have we had saved for CIFAR 10 and for FMNIST
right. So this should the label should have been FMNIST rather than MNIST.
So once we do that we will plot we will perform a we will create a line plot for the training
loss and we will create a line plot for the validation accuracy and see what happens.
So for the training loss as we can see that for CIFAR 10 the training loss reduced much more than
for FMNIST while on the validation accuracy front you can see that the fashion MNIST accuracy
wasn't as high or rather there is quite a big difference between the fashion MNIST accuracy
and the CIFAR 10 accuracy. So what was the what is the conclusion of the take home message from
this entire experiment the take home message is that you need to use there are many pre-trained
pre-training data sets of pre-trained models available you need to carefully choose which
pre-trained model you require for your particular data set. So for example in this case ImageNet was
a very very good candidate for CIFAR 10 but not so much for fashion MNIST probably models that
have been trained on let's say grayscale images might have been a better pre-training idea for
fashion MNIST. So that's the entire take home message from this particular experiment we now
move on to the next and final experiment set of experiments which is fine tuning and training
from scratch. So here we want to understand so right now you understood what sort of pre-training
data set you want to go for now we want to see in terms of from the model perspective how much
of the model do you want to tune or whether you want to retrain the entire model from scratch.
So we have already defined everything in this particular case we will be using the CIFAR
100 data set instead of CIFAR 10 or fashion MNIST. So this is just purely CIFAR 100 and we are going
to use the ImageNet data set as a pre-trained model. So the data model is going to remain the same
that we have explained already in the model class there are certain things that were left out which
you want which I would like to explain right now. So we've already defined if it's pre-trained what
you want to do but now we look at what num freeze unfreeze layers means. So here what you want to
do you want to make sure that we want to unfreeze all of the final layers so layers from the beginning
from the end. So what do I mean by the end so you can imagine we have a model so on the left side
is our training is our initial layer which is basically the input layer and on the right side
we have the output layer. So you want to start from the rightmost layer or the final layer and you
want to move towards the initial layer while unfreezing and why is that as as Plavansar had
already talked about the initial layers contain very general information that is probably applicable
to almost all data sets which is basically edges and small shapes and so on. But as you
move as you keep moving ahead move towards the final output layer these shapes transform into
more general and abstract features until you start seeing whole objects that you want to actually
identify. So based on this logic which layers are more applicable to your data set according to
this logic you want to save as much information as possible from the initial layers which are more
general layers and you want to change the layers right at the end or the final layers because they
are not applicable to your particular data set. So how do we do that if num unfreeze layers is
greater than 0 we first find the number of layers so we count the number of layers which is convolution
2d's and linear's and so on. So whether we have batch norm whether we have linear layer or whether
we have convolutions we are going to count those as each layer and once we have the number of layers
we will start unfreezing them. So the unfreezing counter starts from whatever
start unfreezing counter we have set which is number of layers minus number of unfreeze layers.
So for example in ResNet 18 if you total up all the linear layers the batch norms in the convolution
there are about 50 layers in total I believe it is 52. So when you are setting the number of
unfreeze layers to 31 we are doing 52 minus 31 whatever value we get that is the point where
we start to unfreeze all of the layers and that is exactly the logic that we have written here.
So as soon as the counter it becomes greater than the unfreezing counter which is I believe in this
case 20 21 yeah 21 we start to unfreeze all of those layers. The rest of the stuff is the same
as we have already explained now we put it all together so we have we will create the data module
class or we will create the object of the data module and we will start with shallow fine tuning.
So in shallow fine tuning we have set pretend root 2 and we are setting num unfreeze less to 0
which means that we are only using the final head right we replace because in ImageNet you
have again 512 cross 1000 what we require is 512 cross 100. So we are going to replace that the
head but all of the other layers are going to remain the same that you are not going to free
unfreeze any of the layers and the we define the training and the validation loops as usual
and once training is complete we will get some results and we will see what results we have got.
Now we will go with deep fine tuning so in deep fine tuning what we are going to do is we are going
to set the number of unfreeze layers to 31 all right and we are going to use the pre-trained model
as usual. So now we are going to unfreeze 31 layers after 21 okay so the final 31 layers
are going to be unfrozen again we have the same training loop and the validation loop
again it trains and we will see what results we are going to get because we are if you see the
logic here we are saving all the losses okay so we will see what what results we get.
Now what we are going to do is we are going to train from scratch so we are going to set pretend
to false and obviously number of unfreeze layers is set to 0 because this is not really required for
this particular experiment we are going to set the pre-trained to false so now we are going to
we are not going to use the image net weights so again we have the same training loop we train
the model and finally once we are done with all this we look at the comparison so we will compare
the training losses and we will compare the validation accuracy so as you can see when you
are doing shallow fine-tuning it performs kind of well but then it starts to saturate the performance
starts to saturate and the training from scratch in terms of loss takes over so as you can see
that image net is a great pre-training data set and it is also transferable for c500 but at some
point in time you need to also you need also you need to make sure that the model learns
general or targeted information from your data set as well this is the reason why training from
scratch even though it's we have thrown away or cast away all of that general information from the
image net data set we can still achieve good performance because we are now learning those
general features as well as targeted features for your particular data set hence it starts to
perform better than shallow fine-tuning but deep fine-tuning still performs much better
in terms of loss than both paradigms so here training from deep fine-tuning is taking information
the general information from the image net and taking targeted information from your data set
or in this case the c400 data set what so what happens in terms of validation accuracy we exactly
see the same thing so training from scratch at some point takes over the shallow fine-tuning case
but as you can see deep fine-tuning always performs better than all other paradigms so
a hybrid approach between training from scratch and shallow fine-tuning is deep fine-tuning
and this has been shown to usually work better than almost all cases and another more parameter
heavy version of this would be complete fine-tuning which is fine-tuning the entire model itself
so that is the so what is the take-home message from this particular experiment the take-home
message is that we want to use we want to use a hybrid approach that is neither training from
scratch nor shallow fine-tuning are the best paradigms rather deep fine-tuning or fine-tuning
come the entire model is the best approach so where we can use the general information from
the pre-trained data set and the targeted information from your current data set as well
so yeah that's about it thank you